I'm Bob dustmen on the director of the
McGovern Institute for brain research
and MIT McGovern Institute is a brain
research institute with a dual mission
understand the brain and then apply that
knowledge to help people suffering from
many forms of brain disorders conditions
ranging from dyslexia and autism and
children to Parkinson's disease
Alzheimer's disease macular degeneration
in the elderly as well as depression and
schizophrenia all of that work depends
on the strong foundation and basic
research we currently have 16
distinguished faculty members including
one Nobel laureate and five members of
the National Academy of Sciences we
attract people who want to be part of
this team who want to work on big
problems that can't be solved by one
person working in their lab we put all
these people together in the same place
so we can find these links find the
common threads that tie together these
basic brain mechanisms that contribute
to so many different aspects of human
cognition we believe that basic research
spanning molecules to mind will lead to
the breakthroughs that will benefit
society in the future this belief is
shared by the McGovern's themselves
my wife and I said now we have the tools
to really attack all how to understand
human brain and help to solve mental
illness and brain disease we have with
the McGovern Institute people from
cognitive and brain science department
people from biology department who know
all about cellular and subcellular work
and the neurons people from Western
engineering who run the supercomputers
to help us do the brain scan analysis we
have people from mechanical engineering
to make nanotubes we can insert it into
the brain I think that's the genius of
the Institute is the aspect of total
collaboration bringing many disciplines
together we have created an imbued a
sense of entrepreneurial research we can
start research for which no other source
of funding is available from the first
aha idea of a scientist at the lab bench
some of them are gonna turn into me a
major discovery we're gonna get a cure
for a major mental illness or brain
disease I'm not sure if my reputation
was earned or created by me but I had
this a very strong sense of being the
most normal person on television I was
diagnosed on a monday i knew that
bipolar was once more commonly called
manic depression
I was preparing my first speech which
would happen to be at the McGovern
Institute for brain research and this is
the most i joked at the time that a
mighty stood for my mental illness talk
tipping made a Nobel laureate laugh
every time I come here I find the story
so inspiring perhaps the best way to get
a sense of the McGovern Institute is to
hear just a few of these stories I'm
Nancy kanwisher and I'm an investigator
at the McGovern Institute for brain
research until recently it's been very
difficult to study the neural basis of
cognition because this was sort of
thought to happen all over the brain and
a kind of disorganized wait it was very
controversial whether high-level aspects
of cognition thinking are organized into
compartmentalize separate fits so what
we're expecting to see is a little part
of your brain right in there that
responds when you look at faces like
right now it's going it just turned off
now it's on no thought or like a Swiss
Army knife with a set of highly
specialized components years ago I had a
really brilliant graduate student in
Rebecca Saxe who said that she wanted to
look for brain regions that are involved
in how we think about what another
person is thinking
and I thought that was a pretty cool
question but I just didn't believe for a
moment that the brain had specialized
regions for things that are that
abstract and boy was I wrong the region
of the brain that's selectively involved
in thinking about what another person is
thinking is a prime candidate for a
region that will be affected in autism I
all as best as anybody can tell the core
deficit in autism is one of being able
to understand other people's thoughts
nancy's the perfect example of someone
who spent her whole life understanding
human cognition and in recent years
applying brain imaging technology to
understanding human cognition ready and
now she's gonna take a battery of these
tasks to get that very basic
understanding of what is it that's going
wrong in the brains of these kids
suffering from autism hi I think when
Jackson was about to when most parents
are expecting their children to start
making sounds and say words he said a
couple things he said kitty and he said
daddy he never actually lost any
language but he just didn't gain any
more words than that I think those signs
were enough as an educator for me to
know that there was something up
you hear things about you know children
who are on the autism spectrum who just
love street signs or just love music he
loves everything I love books they are
really fun to read I recently read diary
of a wimpy kid book free when we walked
in to the McGovern Institute he was just
flabbergasted I think he wanted to go
out and come back in again because he
just didn't know what to think about it
and then he just got comfortable there
very quickly what was nice about the
passport for Jackson was he he could
have something tangible this is when I
got right brain scan and there's a
picture something to carry around with
them all day it's an x-ray view and it's
kyle i could x-ray of you enjoy body
where I hold it up like this scanning
any kids is tricky right at the edge of
what you can do in neuroscience research
they're looking for the things that
they're looking for kiki is of autism
inside my brain it's pretty freaky I
tell everybody that we are at MIT doing
this because the finger is on the pulse
there the fact that we could go in and
get a picture of his brain I mean where
else can you do that do you think what
you're doing is gonna help some other
kids yeah I know I know it will help
we're hoping that will discover not just
a characterization of this disorder and
what it looks like but that will also
discover distinct subtypes of autism
and if we can discover that there are
three or even ten different kinds of
autism that will be major progress
autism is an incredibly complex disorder
that just isn't understood at all so
this is a much harder problem than
anything I've tried to do before on the
other hand the stakes are higher it
really matters my name is Kai goossens
and I'm an assistant professor at the
McGovern Institute as I transitioned
from a graduate student to a postdoc two
members of my immediate family became
severely mentally ill as I was starting
to plan my experiments I was interested
in the interaction between chronic
stress and fear both of the members of
my family who had mental illness when
they experienced major life stressors it
made their illnesses so much worse
highest someone who wants to find a
whole new biological approach to
treating a depression and anxiety
disorders for a long time we thought
that we knew how chronic stress impacted
the brain that neurons actually shrink
in response to chronic stress but it
turns out that that's not the whole
story when you chronically stress an
animal neurons in a part of the brain
that is especially important for
generating an expressing fear actually
growth
the part of the brain that shows growth
is called the amygdala it's especially
important in generating and expressing
fear
we've identified now a number of genes
that are turned on only in the amygdala
following chronic stress that as chronic
stress doesn't cause these genes to be
turned on in any other part of the brain
linking those pieces together linking
from a gene to thoughts and emotions I
mean this is an enormous undertaking
once you've identified genes in a
particular brain region that you think
are involved in something you need to
have a way to manipulate those jeans and
see which of those actually lead to
changes in behavior so I'm very hopeful
that what we do in our lab will
eventually result in better treatments
to block the effects of chronic stress
on mental illness hello I'm me and grab
you hi how are you when I was in school
the predominant thought was that a
scientist would do the best science if
he never thought about the possible
application of his sights my attitude is
now completely changed I just want to do
something that really is going to
fundamentally help either patients or
normal people in the way they lead their
lives
and grabeel is interested and how the
brain learns through experience she's
somebody who embodies the molecule to
mind approach of the McGovern Institute
we work on structures in the brain
called the basal ganglia which are right
underneath the cortex let me outside a
number of years ago in our lab we found
that the chemicals in these basal
ganglia are not evenly distributed but
instead they're concentrated differently
to main tissue types ends one of the
world's expert and the neurotransmitter
dopamine as many people know dopamine's
what you lose and Parkinson's disease
great-aunt hi come on in we recently had
the honor of MIT graduate mr. Sid man
can you remember God also an MIT
graduate dad because you've had the
disease now for about 20 years probably
right about that long mr. Sidney you as
severe Parkinson's disease actually took
the time to show the students postdocs
and staff members in our lab what it was
like mr. Sidney is being treated with a
therapy called deep brain stimulation or
DBS for short the Emmis technique wires
electrodes are put deep into the basal
ganglia and you apply a very small
current and the point of that current is
to disrupt the abnormal activity that's
going on at this little point a wire
leads off that electrode down to and
permanently implanted control device
just like a pacemaker it's basically if
you can see the outline it's like right
that big yeah so that's about as large
as they are and they don't think if you
want to feel it he's going to show you
you can touch it so it's just right
under the skin the DBS in your case was
done to help the motor symptoms clearly
correct just feeling
unable to make your body move and being
trapped by your body or trapped and
unable to calm your hand down was very
very uncomfortable for you DBS therapy
is clearly helped mr. Sydney's quality
of life but everyone in the field knows
that we really have to do even better in
our lab we're trying to do that by
understanding how the basal ganglia work
normally and what goes wrong with them
in disorders such as Parkinson's disease
that research that you're doing is going
to affect countless lives and really
gives us a lot of hope that his life
will be improved and many others as well
my name is Chris Moore I'm an associate
professor in the McGovern Institute when
I was seven I started writing a book on
the brain but decided I should delay
that to junior high school so I could
finish it when I have more knowledge the
key to brain dynamics is understanding
how your brain changes his organization
on a millisecond to second time scale
one of the key observations that came
out starting the late 1920s is it often
there's a rhythm to how your brain
functions oscillations that happen save
40 times a second and that's called the
gamma rhythm if you record from people's
brains while they're performing tasks
that ask them to shift their attention
around to listen to one thing as opposed
to another to pay attention to one part
of the room as opposed to another this
40 Hertz oscillation shifts as your
attention shifts the question is what's
the neural circuitry that gives rise to
these rhythms and what do these rhythms
do somehow if we understand this it
might be a key to understanding for
example diseases where the 40 Hertz
oscillations go bad one of those
diseases for example is schizophrenia
what's really been lacking is a way of
turning on and turning off oscillations
of well we need a way of selectively
driving one kind of oscillation or
another in one brain area or another and
that kind of control has been lacking
until now
there's a really remarkable new
technology which allows cells to become
optically sensitive to be sensitive to
light that was co-developed by someone
else here at the McGovern Institute ed
Boyden we've been using optical
controller optogenetics as it's
sometimes called to understand what the
causal role of a neuron is in behavior
pathology and cognition what i'ma show
you here is actually one of the world's
first devices which is now widely used
in hundreds of labs around the world
that allows us to beam light down an
optical fiber from a laser set up this
laser setup allows us to deliver blue
lights or yellow lights down this fiber
so we can turn neurons in the brain on
or off
but neurons in the brain aren't
naturally sensitive to light we have to
make them sensitive to light through our
neuro engineering conference so the way
that we can make cells selectively to
light stimulation is by literally
transferring genes to specific cells in
specific brain areas and when light
shines on these they can actually
activate electrically or silenced
electrically those very sauce we're
incredibly fortunate to have ed Boyden
here at the McGovern Institute at MIT he
continues to develop just amazing new
off to genetic tools this is a
technology that people hadn't even
speculated on five or six years ago
having obtained optical control over
specific cell types in the brain we can
now ask can we induce specific brand
oscillations by driving that cell type
we think that these gamma rhythms are
involved in many many of the brains
operations and as we understand the more
we're going to understand a lot more
about how they may go awry in a whole
variety of mental disorders mit has the
absolutely perfect environment for
developing the new techniques they'll
allow us to ask the new questions that
allow us to open up new paths and
neuroscience the McGovern Institute for
me is a phenomenal addition to our
scientific work into the pleasantness of
doing that work south of corny but I'm
extremely interested in the promise of
neuroscience for society we can do
absolutely anything here there are no
excuses
any kind of expertise we need is right
here in this building right around us I
never end up in a situation where I
think I really want to work on this
problem but I have no idea how and I
don't know who to ask I always know who
to ask they're right here there are a
couple doors down the hall if you want
to combine techniques the way to do it
isn't to work by yourself I think the
McGovern Institute is one of the most
collaborative environments that I have
ever worked in I can't think of anything
else comparable in the world that would
allow radically new ideas from left
field to get out there and you know in
in one short year have huge impact in
the world once you understand the
science of the brain you can't think
about the mind in the same way I've
always viewed MIT as the cauldron of
ideas the place that we go to for new
ideas that are going to really impact
Society so this is where the government
came to MIT for the development of radar
that to help us win world war to the
government came to MIT for the
technology that helped put us on the
moon and now basically we're coming to
MIT and saying where are the new ideas
and the new technology that are going to
give us these new treatments for brain
disorders the curve of progress is
virtually going up vertically things are
happening so quickly the thing I love
about being involved for the McGovern
Institute is because i believe we give
people hope when there's hope and not
defeat or despair on people's mind
progress will prevail and solutions will
be found in order general tip diseases
will be cured I just know that